bien on va faire une interview people
quiz
c'est la rentrée il serait temps de
faire un point bybowl pierre et isabelle
qui a les mains au dessus du buzzer avec
qui couchent claire chazal à l'heure
même où je vous parle là maintenant alès
en titre alain santé claire chazal vite
avec comment s'appelle la mère des
enfants de patrick bruel matin
tout commence pas à oui mais c'est tout
ce que je sais bah oui à mon amende à
amanda sthers
bravo rires qui vient de rentrer en cure
de désintoxication mois attention on est
prêt avec qui s'est marié jean louis
borloo cet été béatrice schönberg
oui quel autre mariage a récemment été
célébré mimie mathy est bas comment
s'appelle le gendre de johnny hallyday
sa page ac
ah non
à monsieur on peut le dire monsieur
beigbeder
oui assez sa passe est officiellement
devenu un vrai jeu morgan tu vas pas lu
la presse cet été en tous les cas oui
avec qui gérard darmon accoucher cet été
je sais il ma mère aussi
alors ça c'est très sérieux là c'est
vraiment le pipole quiz sicilia sarkozy
est elle revenue ces demandes nous avons
50 jean-pierre nouvelle non je crois pas
nathalie pernaut est elle revenue avec
venturi qu'un wii qui a récemment
déclaré qui a récemment déclaré je n'ai
jamais lu un livre de ma vie je n'ai pas
assez bamaba oh non c'est moi je n'ai
pas assez de temps pour lire des livres
dit non non non non non des cargos me
dis là
peter hook la sab et à victoria beckham
exactement avec qui jean michel jarre at
il trompé sa femme c'est tout
non là c'est sa femme il n'a pas trompé
avec personne part qu' antoine de caunes
at il remplacé elsa zylberstein non
d'abord le jeu est vrai pour le jeu on
veut ça fait longtemps que tu as pas
besoin
c'est daphné roulier
elle est jolie elle est très jolie oui
quelle actrice française n'a pas eu des
enfants cette année
carole bouquet
ah là c'est très difficile qui s'est
fait bien baisés cet été mais si bien
sûr si c'est un garçon est un garçon
ben c'est un garçon c'est pas moi c'est
où j'avais à lomé non un indice d'avoir
chez vous un avis ça c'est un indice à
cette douleur mardi à 3
c'est raymond domenech choisit pas
bouder notre maison
ok
pense que ça va plus je pense que ça
n'est plus qu'une pause maison en fin
d'étape
mary comment commence ce que m'ont donné
mais j'ai vu je le connais bien il est
comme new simplement il est obligé de
faire le sérieux c'est normal
yvette remédie résidents mais quand ils
sont beaux souvenirs à bouffer chez lui
comment se prénomme comment se prénomme
le futur mari de paris s'il tonne
nos gars n'ont pas ri soir au deuxième
souffle at on annoncé la fosse
séparation cet été faux ex-aequo chez fo
de chez soi avec qui sort ophélie winter
en ce moment sa mère on sait pas à qui
sort depuis cet été avec une croupière
blonde trouvait dans un casino de la
côte d'azur
j'ai beau jour qui sort depuis cet été
avec une croupière blonde trouvait dans
un casino de la côte d'azur
un type qui a envie de baiser
visiblement n'a rien pour lui depuis
longtemps
laurent gerra milliken mais non il est
pur épousa le mais c'est horrible à ces
horribles à save habitat alors que jack
est toujours avec monique c'est quand
même
alors quel drame a frappé arielle
dombasle cet été à la piscine du ritz
s'est cassé un an et j'ai hâte allons
inviter c'est pas le moment loin et
c'est interdire de rythme parce qu'elle
veut marcher en talons sur le bord de la
piste et on l'a obligé à porter des
séries les grilles des trublions 10
immédiat des sandales deschamps y aura
seulement voilà je sors je m'intéresse
disque important ça existe au monde
extérieur arthur comme et le coût de la
non patchées pas ils sont magnifiques le
dandy ray sur les dinos si c'était à
refaire
3 septembre au théâtre des variétés
jean les fonds elle également